martine turcotte présidente de la
direction du québec acq chef des
affaires juridiques chez bell quitte
l'entreprise pour un départ à la
retraite après 31 ans de carrière au
sein de l'entreprise
elle a travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec 5 chef de la
direction de bell n'a été nommé à
plusieurs reprises l'une des 100 femmes
les plus influentes au canada elle est
avec nous ce soir merci d'être là madame
turc a laissé donc une trentaine
d'années à la tête de cette entreprise
pour le québec grandes transformations
j'imagine de l'entreprise quel bilan
vous faites aujourd'hui mais je pense
une compagnie qui est très innovant
parce que pour exister pendant 140 ans
il faut se renouveler il faut innover
est près du consommateur alors je l' ai
vu passer de notre prise très
diversifiée même dans les pipelines dans
le développement immobilier et on l'a vu
se transformer retourner ces sources
donc les télécommunications et
maintenant les communications dont
comptant plus d'un internet regarder
avec tous les appareils leur est pas de
solaire qui ont changé ça changer la vie
des gens alors a fallu s'adapter au fil
des années alors j'ai vu cette
transformation la massive et c'était
vraiment intéressant et d'ailleurs je
disais aux jeunes
donc je pars à la retraite mais
peut-être si j'étais plus jeune je
recommencerai envoyée imaginez avec tout
ce qui se passe l'intelligence
artificielle ça va être fabuleux pour le
futur vous êtes l'un des rares visage
francophone au sein de la direction de
bell
et est-ce qu'avec votre départ ça va
changer ça est-ce qu'on peut encore
compter sur des visages francophonie ce
je pense que premièrement mercure bébé
qui l'approchaient régime rco parle très
bien français mais recueille d'ailleurs
né à montréal et qui disent qu'à
montréal alors je n'ai aucun doute que
mercure va bien représenté le québec et
d'ailleurs on va avoir une discussion de
personnes qui va être désigné pour me
succéder
ça va être annoncée le 6 janvier donc on
garde un peu le suspense mais je pense
les gens vont vraiment aimé la
succession et j'ai confiance j'ai
vraiment confiance la merco je sais
qu'il va passer beaucoup de temps ici
oui les becs mirko bibic
qui dit d'ailleurs que vous avez été en
quelque sorte son mentor vous donc vous
aviez tout ce qu'il fallait pour prendre
la direction de bell c'est pas quelque
chose qui vous attend en fait j'ai
tellement bien motore mercou que je suis
prête à quitter confère à y avoir
d'autres opportunités qu'on est leur
effectif c'est un bon temps pour faire
le changement
je ne confiant ce absolue en merco j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour lui
il aime le québec qu'il adore le québec
qui va être très présent au québec
alors je parle je peux vraiment partir
un moment où je me sens bien et je sens
que le drapeau québécois est bien
implanté surtout avec la quarantaine on
a quand même un quarantaine de
vice-président et premier vice-président
qui m'ont épaulé durant les derniers
presque dix ans dans mon rôle de
président des élections du québec et ce
sont des gens qui ont une responsabilité
qui valentin pdg de pme au québec
alors j'ai fait tellement c'est énorme
puis j'ai tellement confiance en cette
équipe là que ça me permet vous savez
d'aller dormir sur mes deux oreilles à
refaire le plein d'énergie
puis passer à autre chose parce que donc
est ce que c'est une retraite complète
vous parlez de faire le plein d'énergie
ces nouveaux traite de belles maisons
que j'ai déjà des projets j'ai déjà des
conseils et je veux aider aussi de
retourner dans la communauté je fais
déjà des choses ou auprès d'organismes
communautaires mais des choses qu'ils
obtiennent qui nous passionne alors je
vais prendre un peu de recul j'ai reçu
des bons conseils prend un peu de recul
dans l'année qui vient
rhj est plein d'énergie parce que les
batteries sont à 90%
c'est de les monter à 200 %
mais je vais avoir du plaisir plus le
temps passait le flambeau
il faut trouver le bon moment il ya
clairement de transition c'est clair
parce qu'elle est bon d'une part vous il
ya aussi georges kopp qui quitte alors y
aura du renouveau 2020 chez elle on
s'est dit c'est bon pour l'avenir de
l'entreprise
oui cela dit on peut faire peut-être les
portraits si vous voulez de votre
carrière vos faits d'armes on vous a vu
entre autres dans cette bataille avec
quebecor pour les droits
qu'est ce que vous retenez de ce secteur
un moment marquant dans puis comme vous
le savez belle on n'aime pas tellement
commenté sur des faits divers ou des
disputes commerciales parce qu'au fond
c'est un dispute commerciale entre deux
grands concurrents la concurrence est
forte au québec tant mieux mais ce qu'on
n'a pas émis dans ce cas là est ce moi
particulièrement ce que je n'ai pas aimé
ce que nos aux abonnés ont été pris en
otage et son fait pas son affaire
on ne fait pas son affaire c'est une
dispute qui aurait pu être réglée devant
certains ce qu'avait pu être réglés
devant les tribunaux et d'ailleurs la
cause devant les tribunaux mais on
n'apprend jamais le consommateur en
otage c'était inacceptable avait dépassé
les bornes mais vous pouvez voir j'ai
encore l'appellation un petit peu sur le
sujet mais je pense c'est important de
monter au créneau pour dire écoute ce
serait pas ça se fait pas tout
simplement
vous parlez d'une grande transition dans
les trente dernières années
une entreprise qui s'est améliorée il
reste certainement des choses à
améliorer le des critiques qui vont
aller on entend au sujet de belles le
service à la clientèle entre autres
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiteriez
chasseurs sont dans les bien consciente
ce fait plusieurs années qu'on travaille
parce que le service à la clientèle
c'est une priorité pour nous est-ce
qu'on est là on n'est pas encore là on
s'est amélioré par contre le nombre de
plaintes diminué depuis quatre ans et
plaintes ont diminué
il faut regarder aussi relativement
parce qu'on a plus d'abonnés que les
autres donc un peu plus de planètes mais
relativement les plaintes ont diminué
est-ce qu'on n'est parfait absolument
pas mais on travaille et on continue de
travailler pour améliorer le service à
la clientèle j'ai absolument confiance
on a quatorze mains d'employés au québec
ils ont le coeur bleu comme moi ils
veulent bien faire les choses
et oui on va s'améliorer ce dont vous
êtes le plus fier de votre carrière
madame sûr que l'équipe que je laisse
derrière moi c'est mon collègue j'ai
toujours dit le legs c'est un succession
c'est l'équipe formidable que tu laisses
derrière toi je regarde les 40 la
quarantaine de bp premier vice président
les employés quand le coeur bleu qui
veulent faire avancer les choses qu'ils
veulent faire évoluer la compagnie c'est
ça donc je suis plus fier on peut parler
de dizaines des dizaines de dossiers ce
sont des dossiers qui sont passés les
gens qui dansent derrière
d'ailleurs je le réalise pas je pense
avec aujourd'hui je peux réaliser ou
sont capables de faire les choses sans
moi enfin ça va être bon ça va être une
bonne chose mais vraiment ce l'équipe
dont je suis le plus fier madame sur
quatre merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
mais si madame saint-andré